[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا
نبدا بالعناوين
[موسيقى]
مع الشداد المعارك في بخمه قائدناري
ينتقدوا قاده الجيش الروسي لعدم تزويده
بالسلاح
تصاعد الاحتجاجات في ايران تمديدا
باستمرار مسلسل تسميم الطالبات والسلطات
تبدا حمله اعتقالات لتهدئه الغضب
الايرانيه وزير الدفاع الامريكي يحذر من
اي هجمات ضد قوات بلاده بالعراق
وجوله جديده من المظاهرات في فرنسا
احتجاجا على نظام التقاعد
ونقابات تحذر الحكومه استعدوا لحاله شلل
اقتصادي
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من تطورات
الحرب في اوكرانيا فمع اشتداد المعارك في
الشرق يزداد التمسك الاوكراني بعدم
الانسحاب فيما تزيد روسيا من ضغطها
للسيطره على مزيد من المدن لكن الحقيقه
الثابته ان الطرفين
خسائر في الارواح والعتاد ايضا
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا الاشارات الوارده من موسكو
تشير الى ان باخموت ربما في طريقها الى
السقوط اكدت سلطات دونيتسك المواليه طبعا
لروسيا ان القوات الروسيه اصبحت تسيطر على
نصف مدينه باخمت ومن جانبه اكد وزير
الدفاع الروسي
ان السيطره على مدينه
هجومها في عمق دفاعات القوات الاوكرانيه
اضاف ايضا ان الغرب زاد من وتيره امدادات
الاسلحه الى كيفي اطار ما اسماه
بالاستراتيجيه الامريكيه لكسر روسيا بقوه
السلاح مشيرا الى ان ذلك لن يؤدي الى نجاح
القوات الاوكرانيه
وقد اكد وزير الدفاع ايضا على ان السيطره
على المدينه مدينه باخموت الصناعيه في شرق
اوكرانيا سيشكل اساسا لشن المزيد من
الهجمات الروسيه بتلك المنطقه منطقه دونتس
نتابع
تحرير ضخمه مستمر هذه المدينه هي مركز
دفاعي مهم للقوات الاوكرانيه في دون باس
وستتيح السيطره عليها مزيدا من العمليات
الهجوميه في عمق دفاع القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه كجزء من الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه المتمثله في كسر روسيا بقوه
السلاح تعمل الدول الغربيه على زياده
امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه والمعدات
العسكريه وتوسيع برامج التدريب لافراد
الجيش الاوكراني وفي الوقت نفسه هناك
زياده كبيره في الخسائر بين افراد القوات
المسلحه الامريكيه ففي فبراير فقط ازدادت
الخسائر باكثر من 40% مقارنه بيناير وبلغ
عددهم اكثر من 11 الف جندي
مع اشتداد المعارك في بخموت ومع تزايد
الروايات الروسيه باقتراب السيطره على هذه
المدينه يبقى السؤال ان كانت هذه السيطره
لو تمت ستسمح لموسكو وتجعلها متفوقه
استراتيجيا البنتا يقلل من هذه الخطوه
فبحسب وزير الدفاع
فان فوزا روسيا في بخموت المدينه المهجوره
من اهلها بالنسبه 90% له قيمه رمزيه اكثر
منها عملياتيه اوستن اكد انه لا يستطيع
التنبؤ بموعد انسحاب القوات الاوكرانيه من
باخموت لكنه اكد ان سقوطها لا يعني ابدا
ولا يعني بالضروره ان الروس غيروا مسار
هذه المعركه جاء التقدم في بث بالنسبه
لروسيا وايضا اوكرانيا بعد سقوط الاف
الجنود من الطرفين وايضا تدمير العديد من
المعدات العسكريه رغم ذلك تستمر اوكرانيا
بالتمسك بالمدينه حيث امر رئيسها بلد
مارزلنسكي امر الجيش بارسال تعزيز ات
للدفاع عن المدينه نافيا وجود خلافات
داخليا مع قاده جيشه مراقبون يرون انه اذا
ما استولت روسيا على المدينه فانها لن تجد
تحت ايديها سوى الانقاض حيث ان البلده لم
تعد تضم الا القليل من البنى التحتيه
الصالحه
هذه اول وحده من حرس الحدود الوضع في
المدينه صعب للغايه العدو يقتحم مواقعنا
بفعاليه ومع ذلك لم يحالفهم اي نجاح
وتكبدوا خسائر فادحه حاولوا تفجير جسرين
ولكننا ما زلنا نتلقى كل ما نحتاجه
المدينه قائمه بخموت كانت وستظل جزءا من
اوكرانيا
طبعا اشتعال الحرب في باقمه لا يزال يلقي
بظلاله على علاقه قاده فاجنر والجيش
الروسي حيث ظهرت الخلافات وذلك الى العلم
حيث جدد قائد مجموعه فادنارياف
انتقاداته لقاده الجيش في موسكو قال ان
الاسلحه التي تحتاجها قواته للقتال في
جبهه باخموت لم تصل حتى الان اضاف ايضا
انه من المبكر الحديث عما بعد بخموت لان
المعركه مستمره وليست سهله مشيرا الى ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تقاتل بشراسه في بخموت
ولا تستسلم بسهوله وذلك طبعا في رد على
تصريحات وزير الدفاع الروسي
لنتعرف اكثر حول ما يحدث على الارض معنى
من دوناتسك مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
ومعنى من موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد
الرشد وابدا
بالتطورات الميدانيه بحسب الروايه اذا
مصحه تعبير الاوكرانيه معك رائد
مساء الخير ميسون بالفعل ارتفعت وتيره
القصف المتبادل منذ ساعه تقريبا هنا في
دانيت في العاصمه وهذا مؤشر على ارتفاع
وتيره الاعمال العسكريه في الجبهات الاخرى
طبعا تعتبر بخموت هي اهم الجبهات التي ما
تزال مستعره وما زال جيش الروسي قوات
فاغنر المقصود تتقدم في عده نواحي من
الجبهه الشماليه والجنوبيه والشرقيه تتقدم
لكنها تسيطر على اجزاء كبيره من المدينه
بعد قليل لمعرفه المزيد لكن سنضطر
للانتقال الان الى هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
لوزير الخارجيه العراقي ونظراته الالمانيه
في العراق الى هناك برلين في بدايه السنه
وكان لدوله الرئيس الوزراء والوفد المرافق
له
مباحثات مهمه
مع السيد المستشار الالماني
وتواصلنا الى تفاهمات كبيره حول التعاون
المشترك
في مختلف المجالات
وخاصه في قطاع الطاقه
والكهرباء والعلاقات الاقتصاديه
كما كان لنا حضور قوي
في شباط في مؤتمر ميونخ
وتم اجراء العديد من اللقاءات والمباحثات
هناك
اود في هذه المناسبه ان اسجل كلمه شكر
للسيده الوزيره
ولحكومه المانيا الاتحاديه
على دعم المستمر
للشعب الالماني الدعم المستمر للشعب
العراقي
وبجميع مكوناته
في حربه ضد عصابات والرهابي 11
لقد لعبت سلاح الالماني ميلان
دورا مهما
في كسر شوكه الهجمات
وخاصه الهجمات بواسطه دبابات من قبل
العصابات داعش
وكان انتصارا
للعراقيين
وانتصارا للشعبين وانتصارا لجميع الشعوب
اللي شاركت في هذه المعارك وفي دحر
عصابات داعش ودوله داعش
كما اود ان اشكر على الحكومه الالمانيه
على مساعدتها
السخيه لاعاده اعمار المدن
التي تعرضت للدمار
بسبب الحرب
على داعش وخاصه مدينه موصل ومحافظه
نينوى بصوره عامه
ونسجل الشكر للبرلمان الاتحادي في برلين
على الموقف المشرف
باعترافه بالظلم الذي لحقه بالمكون
واعترافه بان الانتهاكات التي تعرضت له
مشاهدينا سنكتفي بهذا القدر من هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي طبعا بدايه الترحيب
بالوزيره الالمانيه وايضا اشاده بالدور
الالماني في الداخل العراقي طبعا بحال كان
هناك اي تصريحات اخرى تتعلق باي مواقف
معينه او قرارات ننقلها لكم خلال هذه
النشره ولكن نعود الان الى العربيه رائد
الاغبر كان ينقل لنا
المشهد على الارض مقارنه بالروايه
الاوكرانيه وربما يعني اشاره ايضا الى
التضارب في الروايات ما بين الجانبين
الاوكراني وايضا الروسي رائد
شكرا ميسون مره اخرى يعني اكمالا لما
بداته بخصوص التصريحات الهامه لوزير
الدفاع الروسي السرقه
ومؤسس مجموعه
بالفعل يعني قال شويغو بان القوات الروسيه
سيطرت على نسبه 40% من المدينه بشكل يعني
مناقض لما قالته السلطات هنا بان 50 بان
نصف المدينه تحت سيطره الجانب الروسي وهذه
اشاره اخرى للتباين بالتصريحات
بالمعلومات التي تصدر من كل طرف ايضا
بريجوجن قال بان
تصريحاتو بخصوص ما بعد مدينه باخموت يعني
مبكره الحديث عنها لان الاولى ضاربا مثالا
الاولى قتل الدب قبل ان نتحدث عن ما سنصنع
بجلد الدب وبفروته المقصود المعركه ما
زالت مستعره في باخمت وان القوات
الاوكرانيه كما اسلفت لا تستسلم وانها
تقاوم ببساله قالت ايضا بان هذا عشره ما
بين الطرفين مستمره منذ فتره اسمح لي ان
انتقل الى عبد الجواد لمعرفه ان كانت هناك
ردود بهذا الاطار من الجانب الروسي
وبالمقابل عندما تقول الولايات المتحده ان
السيطره الروسيه على باخموت ليست سوى
انتصار رمزي هل موسكو ترى بذلك
الانتصار انه رمزي ام انه بالفعل تحتاج في
هذه المرحله
مرحبا ميسون لك ولرائد في الحقيقه موسكو
طبعا طرفي كل متر اوكراني يمكن السيطره
عليه هو مرحله جديده لكنها طبعا حسب روايه
وزاره الدفاع لا تستعجل الامور كما يرى
البعض وكما يرى قراء العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه لذلك طبعا
ميسون اعاده
فتح النار على وزاره الدفاع طبعا لم يوقع
لم يقابل باي ارد رسمي من قبل الجانب
الروسي او من قبل وزاره الدفاع وما بقيت
عليه دفاع موسكو هو الحديث عن ان كميات
السلاح والذخيره تصل طبعا مجموعه فاغنر من
جهه اخرى طبعا ميسون راحه الكثير من
المحللين السياسيين في البلاد يتحدثون عن
ان مجموعه فاغنر يعني هي في الاول والاخير
هي مجموعه لشركه عسكريه تعمل في تنفيذ
المهمات وطبعا جنودها ومقاتلها هم من
المرت اما طبعا كافه الامور العسكريه
والتنظيم وخاصه عندما يدور الحديث عن
الدعم من الجو من الطيران من صور الاقمار
الصناعيه من المدافع الارضيه ومن الضربات
من مياه البحر الاسود فان الحديث يدور عن
وزاره الدفاع لذلك طبعا لا يحتاج الامر
للكثير من القراءه لمعرفه انفجنر هي احدى
ايدي وزاره الدفاع وكل ما يحدث وكل
المهمات التي تنفذها وتنفذها تكون تحت
مظله ووزاره الدفاع ايضا طبعا ميسون حول
مسالتي بما يخص قضيه ضخمه ضخمه طبعا هي
منطقه محوريه طال فيها النزاع وهي احدى
النقاط التي تشبث فيها الجانب الاوكراني
كما ترى موسكو لذلك السيطره عليها قد تكون
هي المعركه الثانيه الكبيره بعد ماريوبل
الجميع ان يسكن قبل نحو عام في ماريوبل
وكيف وصل التشبت في تلكم من ناموسكم عبد
الجواد الرش شكرا جزي لا لك ومن دوناتس
مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر شكرا جزيلا لك
والان مشاهدينا من باخموت الى جبهه اخرى
تقع شرقيه اوكرانيا ولا تقل اشتعال لنتحدث
هنا عن فولدر التي تقع على بعد 70 ميل
جنوب غرب باخموت يقول مسؤولون اوكرانيون
يقول المسؤولون ان القوات الروسيه خسرت
مئات الجنود من قواتها خلال الشهر الماضي
بعد فشلهم في اقتحام المدينه التي تشهد
اكبر معركه دبابات وذلك منذ اندلاع الحرب
وبحسب مسئولينا اوكرانيين الاوكرانيين
زعموا ان ما لا يقل عن 130 دبابه وناقله
جند مدرعه روسيه تم تدميرها خلال المعركه
بالمدينه وطبعا اشتداد المعارك على جبهات
الشرق دفع القوات الروسيه للتمرد ضد
قيادتهم العسكريه في فولدار الكلام هنا
طبعا على عهد عهده صحيفه التايمز
البريطانيه تمرد تزامنا مع تحديد رئيس
مجموعه فاقنر شبه العسكريه الروسيه من
حدوث انهيار كبير في الخطوط الاماميه بشرق
اوكرانيا تحديد في بخموت في حال لم يتلقى
عناصره الامدادات الكافيه من الاسلحه
والذخيره لطالما كانت فولدار والتي تقع
عند تقاطع الجبهه الشرقيه في منطقه
دوناتسكو الجبهه الجنوبيه في زابوريا ضمن
الاهداف المهمه لموسكو لما لها من اهميه
في منطقه الدومباس وقد استخدمت اوكرانيا
مدينه فولدار كقاعده لعرقله الشحنات على
خط سكه حديد مهم يزود القوات الروسيه
بالامدادات ما يؤكد على اهميه المدينه في
مسار هذه الحرب
وحول هذا الدعم الغربي لك اعلن وزير
الدفاع البولندي ماريوس بلاشاك تزويده
اوكرانيا بعشر دبابات طبعا هي اضافيه من
طراز ليوباردا الالمانيه المانيه الصنع
هذا الاسبوع وقال ان قرار امداد اوكرانيا
المحتمل بالمقاتلات الجويه الغربيه يجب
اتخاذه على مستوى الحلفاء في النيتو مشيرا
الى الاستمرار في تعزيز الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه
ببطاريات باتريوت ودبابات ليوبارد واوضح
وزير الدفاع البولندي ان وارسو قدمت منذ
بدايه الصراع مساعدات عسكريه
تزيد على 2.2 مليار يورو
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل تتعهدان بزياده
التنسيق لمنع ايران من امتلاك سلاح نووي
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ونكمل من
ايران حيث افادت وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه
افدت ان وزاره الداخليه الايرانيه اعلنت
اعتقال اشخاص على صله بقضيه تسميم الطلاب
طبعا هذا جاء على لسان مساعد وزير
الداخليه الايراني للشؤون الامنيه الذي
اشار الى اعتقال بعض الاشخاص في خمس
محافظات على صله بتسميم الطلاب من جانبه
اكد الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي على
ضروره تاهب اجهزه المخابرات للتعامل مع
التهديدات الامنيه في اي مجال بما في ذلك
تهديدات ضد الصحه العامه في المدارس
وبهذا الاطار نظم العشرات من اهالي الطلبه
في عاصمه كردستان احتجاجا على تصميم
الطالبات متابعه
[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم
على كل مزيد معنا من دبي الصحفي المختص في
الشان الايراني مسعود الفك اهلا بك
بقضيه الاعلان عن القاء القبض على اشخاص
لهم علاقه بما يحدث في ايران من تصميم
للطالبات هل هي خبر مبشر بالخير بانه
بدانا نفهم ما الذي يحدث على الارض وسنفهم
ذلك ام ماذا
تحياتي الكرام
طبعا ما تحدث عنه ميرا احمد هو النائب
المساعد السياسي
عفوا المساعده الامني لوزير الداخليه
الايرانيه
كان اعلان غامض تم اعتقال بعض الاشخاص ومن
بين هؤلاء
عناصر غير معامده غير معامده دائما تستخدم
في الادب بادبيات النظام الايراني يعني
ليست من المعارضين وتم نصيحتها
وادارتها هذا هذا الغموض الكامل في هذا
الحديث وفي هذا الخبر انا باعتقادي لا
يبشر بخير
ما الذي تريد ان تخفيه السلطات الايرانيه
هناك فرضيات كثيره يا ميسون ولكن هناك
فرضيه تقول بان الان النظام الايراني
يحاول
يخلق نوع من محاكاه بعد السقوط لذا خلق
وضع امني يخيف الشارع بان لو سقطنا نحن
سيكون اللامن هو البديل لهذا النظام هذه
الحاله طبعا هذا التصرف باعتقادي هو شيء
ذو حدين الا ان النظام قد يعتقد بانه حتى
لو صارت احتجاجات على هذا الوضع يمكن
التحكم بها يمكن يعتقل كما حصل اليوم
اليوم شاهدت عده مدن احتجاجات فتم
الاعتقال تم القمع تم فضل احتجاجات لذا
النظام يحضر نفسه لمثل هذه الحاله وهل
تعتقد بانه سينجح بهذا الاطار بهذه الورقه
التي يستخدمها الورقه الامنيه
الورقه الامنيه لحد الان عندما الانظمه
تفقد شرعتها وتفقد شعبيتها لم تبقى لها
الا الورقه الامنيه عندما نقول هل تنجح ام
لا تنجح هذا يعني قد تكون هناك ورقه بديله
اخرى والورقه البديله الاخرى للامنيه يجب
ان تكون ورقه الشرعيه وهذه مفقوده لذا
النظام يلعب ورقته الوحيده
كان معنا من دبي الصحفي المختص في الشان
الايراني مسعود الفك شكرا جزيلا لك
وفي ايران ايضا ولكن فيما يتعلق بالاتفاق
النووي اكد دبلوماسيون في مجلس المحافظين
طبعا هو تابع للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه اكدوا للعربيه ان تمهل الدول
الغربيه بطرح مشروع قرار يدينه ايران
بخصوص انشطتها النوويه جاء لاعطاء طهران
فرصه للتعاون مع الوكاله الدبلوماسيون
اشاروا الى انه قد تم تبليغهم بالتوصل
للاتفاق محسوس مع ايران لتوضيح مسائل
عالقه حول مواقعها السريه من طرف رفائيل
الجروسى احد الدبلوماسيين وصف هذا التمهل
من قبل الدول الغربيه بانه الهدوء ما قبل
العاصفه مضيفا ان اجتماع مجلس المحافظين
في يونيو المقبل سيعيد تقييم التعاون بين
ايران والوكاله وسيتخذ على اساسها الخطوات
المناسبه
ياتي هذا في وقت تعهدت فيه الولايات
المتحده وايضا اسرائيل بزياده التنسيق
لمنع ايران من امتلاك سلاح نووي جاء ذلك
في بيان امريكي اسرائيلي مشترك صدر عقب
اجتماع مستشار الامن القومي الامريكيه مع
نظيره الاسرائيلي في واشنطن حيث بحث
الجانبان الملف النووي الايراني البيان
اضاف ان هناك اتفاقا على احباط انشطه
ايران الاقليميه العدائيه في الشرق الاوسط
بعد مراسل العربيه باقتحام قوات اسرائيليه
خاصه مخيم جنين في الضفه الغربيه في مدوه
سفارات الانذار في المخيم بعد ان حاصرت
القوات الاسرائيليه منزلا واندلعت
اشتباكات عنيفه على اثرها واعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي قتل اربعه فلسطينيين في المخيم
من بينهم منفذ عمليه حوار نتابع
شباب شباب
نزلت قوات خاصه اياها هياها يا شباب
التطورات معنا من رام الله عبد الحفيظ
جعوان مراسل العربيه اهلا بك عبد الحفيظ
اخر المعلومات والتطورات وماذا عن المسيره
التي تم الاعلان عن اسقاطها في جنين
ميسون حتى هذه اللحظه ما زال هناك
اشتباكات ومواجهات عنيفه تدور في انحاء
مخيم جنين بعد ان داهمت قوه اسرائيليه
خاصه المنطقه الشرقيه في المخيم منذ نحو
ساعه ونصف قوه خاصه اسرائيليه كانت في
شاحنه للبضائع وبعدها قدمت الى المخيم
تعزيزات عسكريه كبيره حاصرت منزل تقول
اسرائيل انه يتحصن فيه عدد من المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين احدهم على الاقل تتهمه
اسرائيل بتنفيذ عمليه حواره التي جرت منذ
نحو تسعه ايام وادت الى قتل مستوطنين تم
قصف المنزل المحاصر بنحو تسعه صواريخ
محموله على الكتف والى هذه اللحظه ما زالت
القوات الاسرائيليه تحاصر هذا المنزل
وتدور اشتباكات عنيفه في محيط المكان وفق
مصادر اسرائيليه الصحفيه قالت ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قام بقتل اربعه فلسطينيين داخل
هذا المبنى وما زال يحاصر فلسطينيين اخرين
وفق وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه فان الجيش الاسرائيلي قتل
فلسطينيا واحدا واصاب خمسه اخرين بجروح
نقلوا الى المشافي القريبه في مدينه جنين
خلال هذه الاشتباكات الجيش الاسرائيلي
اضافه للوحدات الخاصه وحدات القناصه
يستخدم ايضا طائرات الدرون والطائرات بدون
طيار واحده من هذه الطائرات طائره درون
كبيره الحجم قام المقاتلون قبل قليل
باسقاطها وارسلنا صورا للحظه اسقاط هذه
الطائره ضمن هذه المواجهه الكبيره التي
تشهدها هذه المدينه والمخيم عمليا اللافت
في هذه العمليه انها عبد الحفيظ كونك ذكرت
الصور التي ارسلتها لاسقاط هذه المسيره
سنظهر هذه الصور الان التي ارسلتها ونكمل
الحديث معك
[موسيقى]
تفضل عبد الحفيظ
الفت في هذه العمليه ميسون انها جرت في
يعني وقت العصر وهو وقت لم نشهد يعني مثل
هذه العمليات ان تجري وقت العصر عاده تكون
ازمه
يعني الموظفين للطلاب للاسواق وبالتالي
دخول القوات الاسرائيليه في مثل هذا الوقت
الى قلب مخيم جنين والى مدينه جنين من
شانه ان يعني ان ينتج الكثير من الضحايا
في صفوف الفلسطينيين وان نشهد ايضا
مواجهات قويه جدا ايضا هناك طائره مروحيه
اسرائيليه هبطت قبل ان ندخل طائره مروحيه
الطائره المروحيه بس عندي سؤال لانك قلت
انه المواجهات تكون قويه جدا حجم هذه
المواجهات وعن من نتحدث الان
هذه تماما تشبه ميسون اذا تتذكرين في
السادس والعشرين من يناير من هذا العام
عندما اقامت القوات الاسرائيليه باقتحام
مدينه جرين وقامت بقتل 10 فلسطينيين فيما
اعتبره الفلسطينيون المجزره الاولى الذي
يرتكبها الجيش الاسرائيلي هناك في جنين
كانت ايضا يعني في وقت الظهيره ايضا في
مدينه نابلس قبل نحو اسبوعين عندما قتلت
القوات الاسرائيليه احد عشر فلسطينيا كانت
ايضا في وقت النهار وبالتالي عندما تدخل
القوات الاسرائيليه في وقت النهار الى
المدن الفلسطينيه المقتظه بالسكان
فبالتالي النتيجه تكون عاده دمويه
والحصيله تكون كبيره للغايه عمليا اسرائيل
تتحدث عن قتل اربعه فلسطينيين ولكن طواقم
الاسعاف والهلال الاحمر يعني تتلقى نداءات
استغاثه من مواطنين في الحي المحاصر
والمباني المحاصره ولكن تواكم الاسعاف حتى
الان لم تستطع ان تصل الى المكان كل ما
يعني فقط تمكنت من نقل خمسه جرحى من محيط
المكان اضافه الى فلسطيني يعني الضحيه
وحيد هو محمد غزاوي اصيب برصاصه بصدر خلال
الاشتباكات التي يخوضها المسلحون
الفلسطينيون مع القوات الاسرائيليه
التي كنت تتحدث عنها لانه انتهى الوقت
تفضل عبد الحفيظ
نعم هذا لافت جدا طائره مروحيه هبطت بقرب
المخيم وعلى ما يبدو انها تريد اخلاء بعض
الاصابات لا نعرف اذا كانت الاصابات من
الجيش الاسرائيلي وفق بيانات مقاتلين
فلسطينيين ام الذين تم اغتيالهم من داخل
المبنى المحاصر حتى هذه اللحظه في جنين
الى العراق الان حيث اكد رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شياع السوداني اكد ان حكومته
تتبع علاقات متوازنه مع المحيط الاقليمي
والدولي تستند الى المصالح المشتركه والى
احترام السياده اشار خلال استقباله لوزير
الدفاع الامريكي الى ان استقرار العراق
مفتاح لامن المنطقه والاستقرارها وان
العراق يلعب دور في تقريب وجهات النظر
وخفض التوترات بالمنطقه من جهته اكد وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه التزام بلاده بدعم
استقرار العراق
وزير الدفاع الامريكي اوستن اضاف ايضا ان
رئيس الوزراء العراقي اكد له ضمانه امن
القوات الامريكيه في العراق من جهات غير
تابعه للدوله طبعا في اشاره بحسب
المراقبين الى الميليشيات المواليه لايران
نتابعها
يجب ان نكون قادرين على العمل بسلامه
وامان لتنفيذ دور الحيوي لتقديم المشوره
للقوات العراقيه لذا اود ان اشكر رئيس
الوزراء السوداني ووزير الدفاع العباسي
على التزامهما اليوم بضمان ان قوات
التحالف الموجوده في العراق بطلب عراقي
ستتم حمايتها من العناصر التابعه وغير
التابعه للدوله نركز على مهمه هزيمه داعش
هذا هو هدفنا الوحيد هنا والتهديدات
والهجمات على قواتنا تقوض مهمتنا
اصلا قال ايضا ان القوات الامريكيه مستعده
للبقاء في العراق وذلك بطلب من الحكومه
العراقيه
القوات الامريكيه مستعده للبقاء في العراق
وذلك بطلب من الحكومه العراقيه وستنشط هذه
القوات في مجالات غير قتاليه على صعد
المساعده والمشوره لدعم حرب العراق ضد
الارهاب هذه مهمه حاسمه ونحن فخورون بدعم
شركائنا العراقيين لكن يجب ان يكون
التعاون تحت شرط السلامه والامن لانجاز
هذا العمل
وفي هذه الاثناء شددت وزيره خارجيه
المانيا الليالينا على ضروره تجنب العنف
العراق قالت ان تجدد العنف يسبب الارهاب
او نفوذ ايران سيضر بالمنطقه اكدت وزيره
خارجيه المانيا على ان استقرار العراق
عاملا رئيسيا للاستقرار الاقليمي
على كل المزيد معنا من بغداد مراسل
العربيه منتظر الرشيد اهلا بك منتظر اهميه
هاتين الزيارتين لوزير الخارجيه الدفاع
الامريكي وايضا الخارجيه الالمانيه خبرنا
نعم ميسون زياره وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
تاتي مع اقتراب ذكرى غزو العراق
اذا وزير الدفاع الامريكي وصل الى بغداد
وايضا التقى رئيس الحكومه اجرى مؤتمرا
صحفيا ومن ثم انتقل الى اقليم كردستان
والى اربيل تحديدا التقى هناك رئيس
الاقليم بارزاني ملفان مهمان على ما يبدو
كان يحملهما طبعا وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ونقشهما طبعا مع كبار المسؤولين العراقيين
الاول يتعلق بمستقبل مصير المستشارين
الامريكيين المدربين الامريكيين
مصير هذا التعاون مع العراق يبدو انه تم
تجديد التعاون والشراكه في هذا المجال الى
السنوات المقبله وهذا طبعا ما شدد عليه
وزير الخارجيه الذي زار واشنطن ايضا مؤخرا
وبصحبته وفد امني ايضا عراقي كبير اذا هذا
الملف الاول هو حمايه هذه القوات وايضا
حمايه
يعني
قوافل الدعم اللوجستي القادمه من الكويت
والتي دائما ما تتعرض طبعا الى هجمات على
الطرق الرئيسيه هذا ما اكد عليه في هذا
الملف اما الملف الاخر الذي تحدث عنه وزير
الدفاع الامريكي هو مساله نقل عائلات داعش
العراقيه الى مخيم الجدعه داخل الاراضي
العراقيه من مخيم الهول في الشرق السوري
وايضا طالبت دول الدول الاخرى التي لديها
عائلات هناك يحملون جنسيات اوروبيه بنقلها
هؤلاء وحذوي حذو العراق لان العراق اقام
مخيما بدا عمليات التاهيل لهؤلاء تمهيدا
طبعا لاعادتهم الى مناطقهم معظمهم طبعا من
النساء والاطفال لكن هناك الكثير منهم ما
يزالون في الشرق السوري وهذا يؤرق
الولايات المتحده ايضا لانهم عباره عن
قنابل موقوته قد تنفجر في اي لحظه اذا
بقيوا طبعا هناك تحت حمايه طبعا قوات قسده
التي تقوم بتامين الحمايه مثل هذا المخيم
ولدينا زياره وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
يبدو ان التصريحات لا زالت مستمره حتى هذه
اللحظه لا اعلم ان كان المؤتمر الصحفي
لازال مستمر اخر التصريحات تتحدث عن خطر
هجمات ايران عبر حدود العراق بانها تعتبر
خطيره جدا على المنطقه منتظر
يعني المؤتمر الصحفي انتهى قبل قليل بين
وزير الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين وايضا
نظيرته الالمانيه تحدث الطرفان طبعا عن
ايضا ملف ثاني مهمان الاول يتعلق بالطاقه
والثاني الاستثمارات الالمانيه هنا في
العراق في هذا المجال طبعا سواء في مجالات
الغاز والطاقه وايضا الكهرباء اذا المانيا
تبحث عن بيئه
لاستثمار شركاتها في العراق وهذا ما تعمل
عليه طبعا بشكل متواصل ربما تصل الى مراحل
متقدمه خلال الاشهر القليله المقبله من
بغداد مراسل العربيه منتظر الرشيد شكرا
جزيلا لك
اعلنت هيئه الاركان العامه الكوريه
الشماليه ان كوريا الجنوبيه قصفت
بالمدفعيه منطقه قريبه من الحدود بين
الكوريتين مشيره الى ان بيون تعتبر هذه
الاعمال بمثابه استفزاز قالت الهيئه في
بيان لها ان كوريا الجنوبيه اطلقت حوالي
30 قذيفه في ميدان في مدينه باجو بمحافظه
عند الجزء الغربي من الجبهه
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
جمهوريون بمجلس الشيوخ يضغطون لاقرار
تشريع جديد امريكي يسمح لبايدن بحظر تطبيق
تيك توك
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ونكمل من
فرنسا حيث تظاهر مئات الالاف احتجاجا على
مشروع قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد هذا ويعد
هذا التحرك امتدادا لتحركات سابقه اخرى
حدثت خلال الشهرين الماضيين الحراك ياتي
تحت شعار اغلاق فرنسا حيث يشمل قطاعات
استراتيجيه فضلا عن انه يمهد الطريق امام
بدايه اضراب مفتوح يمتد لايام
طبعا مشاهدينا تظاهرات هذا اليوم في فرنسا
هي سادس تحرك منذ التاسع عشر من يناير
الماضي ضد اصلاح نظام التقاعد الذي اقترحه
الرئيس ماكرون زادت النقابات الضغط اعلنت
ان البلاد على استعداد للعيش في حاله شلل
كامل في محاوله طبعا لحمل الحكومه على سحب
مشروع القانون حيث يتم مناقشته في مجلس
الشيوخ هذا الاسبوع تتركز المعارضه بصوره
خاصه على بند من هذا الاصلاح ينص على رفع
سن التقاعد القانوني من 62 الى 64 عام
ويصطدم بمعارضه غالبيه الفرنسيين حيث
يصفونه بالظالم هددت نقابات عماليه بشل
الاقتصاد الفرنسي مع توقف العمل في عده
قطاعات من ابرزها اضراب مفتوح في محطات
الشركه الوطنيه للسكك الحديديه وقد توقعت
توقفت ثلاثه من المحطات الاربعه للغاز
الطبيعي المسال والتي تسمح باستيراد الغاز
الى فرنسا توقفت عن العمل لمده اسبوع لم
يكن الحال احسن في قطاع الطيران حيث الغيت
خمس رحلات جويه في مطار شارل دي غول
بباريس وحوالي ثلث رحلات مطار اورلي
الدولي يراهن ماكرون بقسم كبير من رصيده
السياسي اذ انه يصر على المضي قدما في
القانون رغم الاستياء حياله حيث ترى
الحكومه في مشروع القانون اهميه لمواجهه
التدهور المالي لصناديق التقاعد وشيخوخه
السكان
مشاهدينا على كل ننتقل الان الى هذه الصور
المباشره نشاهدها معكم الان من داخل باريس
ومعنا ايضا من هناك مراسل العربيه فاديه
الدهوك انقل لنا المشهد من عندك ما الذي
يحدث
حول هذا
التظاهرات
بحسب ما فهمت في بعض التعديلات يمكن ان
تقرر اليوم ولا لا
هناك تعديلات كثيره قوى اليسار المعارضه
لهذا المشروع بالدرجه الاولى طرحت الاف
التعديلات الاف التعديلات على نصوص وبنود
هذا القانون ايضا هناك تعديلات تناقش في
مجلس الشيوخ لكن حتى الان لا يوجد معلومات
كانت هذه التعديلات سوف تمر من من
المستبعد ان يتمكن مجلس النواب او حتى
مجلس الشيوخ من التوافق على هذه التعديلات
لتهدئه الامور الحكومه ما زالت مصره على
السير قدما في هذا القانون والمعارضه
تطالبها بالاستماع اليها والى صوت الشارع
يقولون ان هذا اليوم هو يوم لاغلاق فرنسا
لاصابه
الاقتصادم الشلل حتى
عذرا لضيق الوقت فادي بدي افهم شو اللي عم
بيصير على الارض ايضا في اشتباكات وحجم
هذه الاشتباكات ولماذا
[موسيقى]
في التظاهر الفارسيه الموكب الباريسي يسير
بشكل سليم حتى الان هناك بعض الموانا
المناوشات المحدوده جدا بين المتظاهرين او
بين عدد من الشبان الذين يعرفون بانهم
متطرفون من قوى اليسار مجموعات شابه حذرت
الشرطه من انهم سوف يكونون سوف تكون
اعدادهم نحو 400 شخص ايضا هناك مواجهات
بين الشرطه والمتظاهرين اندلعت في مدينه
ليون وسط وجنوب فرنسا في وقت سابق اليوم
لكن حتى الان الامور هادئه نسبيا نوعا ما
والمناوشات محدوده جدا لكن كيف ستتطور
ستتطور الامور لا نعلم هناك انتشار امني
كثيف جدا الاف عناصر الشرطه منتشرين في
الشوارع اليوم هناك مساله مهمه ان هذا
الاضراب اثر على قطاع الطاقه هناك اخبار
وردت قبل قليل بانقطاع التيار الكهربائي
عن احدى المناطق في او عن احدى المدن في
منطقه بادوكالي وهناك نحو 1500 شخص في هذه
المنطقه الان يعيشون من دون تيار ك وكل
ذلك بسبب اضراب الموظفين في محطات التوليد
عن العمل اليوم الاضراب الذي اثر على حركه
المواصلات كما ذكر النقل والطيران صح في
حركه المواصلات بين بريطانيا قطاع النقل
والطيران
المدن التي تاثرت بشكل كثير او الخطوط بين
فرنسا وبريطانيا هي اكثر المناطق التي
تاثرت بهذا الاضراب هناك
هيئه الطيران المدني دعت شركات الطيران
الى الغاء ما بين نحو 20 الى 30% من رحلات
الطيران اليوم في مطار شال دوغول وايضا في
مطار اورلي اليوم وغدا الاربعاء كان معنا
من باريس مراس العربيه فادي الدهوك شكرا
جزيلا لك وطبعا نستمر على هذه الصور التي
تاتينا من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس وخروج
مئات الالاف طبعا احتجاجا على مشروع قانون
اصلاح نظام التقاعد نستمع
[موسيقى]
الى زياده الان وموجز الخامسه الرياضيات
شكرا ميسون واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في
اياب دوره 16 لمسابقه دوري ابطال اوروبا
لكره القدم يلتقي الليله تشيلسي مع ضيفه
بروسيا دورتموند الالماني وكانت مباراه
الذهاب بين الفريقين قد انتهت بفوز
دورتموند بهدف المقابل لا شيء وياتي
الفريق الانجليزي من فوز على ليدز يونايتد
في الدوري المحلي يوم السبت الماضي وفي
المقابل يحتل بروسيا دورتموند المركز
الثاني في دوري بلاده متاخرا بفارق
الاهداف عن بايرن
رؤيه نتيجه الخصم في الدوري الالماني هم
يمرون بفتره رائعه الى حد كبير يفوزون
بالمباريات باستمرار اعتقد انها عشر
مباريات متتاليه وهذا يوضح لك ما هي فريق
يهاجمون يدافعون لديهم افراد جيدون ومدرب
جيد
سيكون مشتعلا انا متاكد تماما وسنقدم كل
شيء للفوز بالمباراه والتاهل انها مباراه
كبيره وحماسيه هي فرصه للتاهل الى دور
الثمانيه وليله خاصه في سان فروج كل
تفكيرنا ينصب في محاوله ان نكون ايجابيين
ونحول المضي قدما والفوز بالمباراه
لا اعرف اذا كانت اكبر مباراه في مسيره
ولا اهتم لان الامر لا يتعلق به انه يتعلق
بفريقه بروسيا دورتموند وانا جزء من هذا
الفريق اتذكر اننا لعبنا ايضا في ربع
نهائي عامين امام اشبيليه انها ايضا
مباراه مهمه جدا وبعد ذلك لعبنا امام
مانشستر سيتي اسف في ربع النهائي امام
مانشستر سيتي كانت ايضا مهمه للغايه هي
مباراه مهمه جدا بالنسبه لنا في النادي
ونريد ان نظهر انه يمكننا المنافسه على
هذا المستوى واننا على استعداد للقتال من
اجل ان نكون احد الفرق الثمانيه الاولى في
اوروبا ولكن في نهايه المطاف نريد فقط ان
نستحق ذلك واذا استحقينا التاهل سنكون
سعداء للغايه
وضمن الدوري نفسه لمسابقه دوري ابطال
اوروبا لكره القدم سيكون بنفيكا البرتغالي
على موعد مع كلوب بروجال بلجيكيه ونجح
الفريق البرتغالي بالفوز ذهابا خارج ملعبه
بهدفين دون مقابل ويحتل صداره الدوري
بفارق ثمان نقاط عن بورتو صاحب المركز
الثاني من جانبه يتبروج من هزيمه ثقيله
امام اوستنند ضمن الدوري البلجيكي لكره
القدم
سحبت امس قرعه بطوله كاس الملك سلمان
للانديه العربيه لكره القدم في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض وحلف المجموعه الاولى
الترجي التونسي الاتحاد السعودي والمتاهل
الثالث والشرطه العراقيه في المجموعه
الثانيه اسد القطري الوداد المغربي
المتاهل الرابع والهلال السعودي في
المجموعه الثالثه الزمالك المصري والمتاهل
الخامس والنصر السعودي والمتاهل الثاني
المجموعه الرابعه ضمت شباب بلوزداد
الجزائري الرجاء المغربي المتاهله السادس
وكذلك المتاهل الاول
تغلب الفتح على الهلال بهدفين مقابل هدف
واحد في مباراه مؤجله من الجوله الثامنه
عشره للدوري السعودي لكره القدم تفاصيل
هذه المباراه في التقرير التاليه
[موسيقى]
رياض من اجل اللحاق بركب المقدمه
الضيوف يبادرون بمهاجمه مرمى عبد الله
المعيوف من خلال محاولات جريئه بحثا عن
كسر نتيجه التعادل
[تصفيق]
هجمات الفتح منحت البرازيلي بطرس الوصول
الى مرمى الهلال غير ان حكم اللقاء الغى
الهدف بداعي التسلل لمصلحه الهلال عند
المحاولات الهلاليه استمرت وعبد الله
الحمدان يفشل في تحويل الكره الى المرمى
الفرنسيه مدرب المنتخب السعودي يتابع
المباراه الفتح ينجح قبل انتهاء الشوط
الاول بخمس دقائق في احراز هدف التقدم عن
طريق الاسباني كريستيانو
فتح يتقدم بالهدف الاول وهدف مع انطلاق
الشوط الثاني قاد الدوسري ورفاقه اكثر من
هجمه بحثا عن التعادل
الاسباني كريستيانو يظهر مجددا يراوغ
ويسدد والمعيوف بدوره يتصدى للكره
محاولات الهلال استمرت قبل ان ينجح خالد
الغنام في مضاعفه النتيجه باحرازه هدفا
ثانيا للفتح
الهلال لم يستسلم في محاولات للنجاه من
الخساره وتمكن من تضييق الفارق بهدف عن
طريق صالح الشهري في الوقت المحتسب بدل
الضائع
[تصفيق]
الحكم البرتغالي ارطغرل دياز ينهي
المباراه فوز ثمين للفتح وخساره ثانيه
للهلال في البطوله التي يحمل لقبها
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك ميسون
[موسيقى]
شكرا زياد مع تصاعد الانتقادات الامريكيه
لتطبيق تيك توك بسبب مخاوف من استهداف
الحكومه الصينيه لبيانات المستخدمين يدفع
الجمهوريون في مجلس الشيوخ لاقرار تشريع
جديد يهدف الى منحه اداره الرئيس جو بايدن
سلطات جديده لحظر التطبيقات التي قد تشكل
مخاطر امنيه بما في ذلك تيك توك نتابع
اداره بيض تريد الصلاحيه للتعامل مع مخاطر
التيك توك للتاكد من ان البيانات الحساسه
ليست مكشوفه للصين من اجل الحصول على هذا
النوع من الرقابه يدفع البيت الابيض
الكونجرس لمنحه سلطه قانونيه على منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي يتم تطوير هذا التشريع
من قبل السيناتور الديمقراطي مارك وارنار
واذا تمريره يمكن ان يكون للحكومه
الامريكيه سلطه حظر تيك توك المملوكه
للصينيين بشكل كامل من الولايات المتحده
لكن حسب نيويورك تايمز ليس هذا هو الهدف
فكره التشريع هي السماح لتيك توك بالعمل
في الولايات المتحده ولكن تحت اعين
الحكومه الساهره يبدو ان منصه تيك توك على
وشك ان تصبح احدث اضافه في حرب
التكنولوجيا بين واشنطن وبكين حرب تنطوي
على العديد من الفصول الاخرى ابرزها
بعنوان الرقائق الدقيقه
في السنوات الاخيره انفقت الولايات
المتحده 52 مليار دولار على تصنيع اشباه
الموصلات المحليه لتقليل اعتماد امريكا
على رقائق الكمبيوتر المصنوعه في اسيا
بينما منعت الصين منذ فتره طويله العديد
من الخدمات الامريكيه عبر الانترنت ابرزها
جوجل ومتى ويوتيوب
ومشاهدينا هذه العوده للصور المباشره من
فرنسا تاتينا الان تحول الاشتباكات الى
اعمال تخريب حتى هذه اللحظه طبعا المزيد
حول ما يحدث في الارض في نشرات القادمه
مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]